ويشير المسؤولون الإسرائيليون إلى أنهم
يخططون لاستئناف
هجومهم العسكري بمجرد
انتهاء هذا التوقف، حيث قال وزير الدفاع يف غانت
أمس نقلاً عن أي
مفاوضات أخرى ستعقد تحت النار إن
إسرائيل ترفض دعوات الولايات المتحدة
لوقف هجومها في  من أجل
محاولة مواصلة
المفاوضات بشكل جيد أولا دانا فقط لنكون
واضحين بشأن شروط هذه الصفقة. وقد
وافقت إسرائيل بالفعل على أنها
ستواصل وقف القتال يوما بعد يوم
بعد انتهاء الأيام الأربعة طالما
استمرت حماس في إطلاق سراح الرهائن وبالتالي فإن
الكرة  هو بالفعل في ملعب حماس إذا
أرادت حماس أن ترى تمديدًا
للتهدئة والقتال، فيمكنها الاستمرار في
إطلاق سراح الرهائن إذا اختارت عدم
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، فإن نهاية
التهدئة هي مسؤوليتها وليس مسؤولية إسرائيل
لأنها تحتجز هؤلاء الرهائن بشكل
غير قانوني تمامًا  وضد
كل حدود اللياقة الإنسانية أو قوانين
الحرب، لذا فقط لكي نكون واضحين،
سنرى حقًا ما الذي ستختار حماس فعله في نهاية المطاف،
نعم، لذا سيكون من الواضح ما إذا كانت حماس بعد انتهاء
فترة التوقف التي دامت 4 أيام تقول حسنًا، هذا هو
التالي  قائمة الرهائن التي
سنطلق سراحها ستواصل إسرائيل
وقفها العسكري، ولا
شك أن هذا صحيح، 10 رهائن
يوميًا لمدة أيام تساوي إطلاق حماس لـ
10 رهائن، هل ستواصل إسرائيل
وقف القتال الذي يعد جزءًا من
شروط الصفقة التي ستطلقها إسرائيل  لقد وافقت على
هذا الالتزام الذي تعهدت به إسرائيل،
والآن كما قلت قبل أن تصبح الكرة في
ملعب حماس، هل قدم أي من الرهائن
الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم أي معلومات
أو معلومات استخبارية لإسرائيل والمسؤولين الأمريكيين
يمكن أن تساعد في تحديد مكان أولئك الذين
ما زالوا في
غزة؟  في البداية، أه،
التعرف على استجوابات هؤلاء
الرهائن، لذا سأمتنع عن التعليق
حتى أه يمكن أن يكون هناك المزيد من الوقت
لحدوث ذلك، نحن نتحدث فقط عن
اليومين الأخيرين اللذين
تم إطلاق سراح الرهائن فيهما والساعات الأولى
لقد كان الأمر يتعلق حقًا برعاية
صدماتهم بسبب آلامهم وأيضًا
جمع شملهم مع
عائلاتهم، لذا سيستغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت حتى نحصل على هذه المعلومات حتى
تحصل إسرائيل على تلك المعلومات ولكن
يمكنك التأكد من أن إسرائيل تركز على
تعلم كل ما في وسعها حول
أماكن وجودهم وغيرها من
المعلومات بناءً على المحادثات التي
أجروها مع الرهائن المفرج عنهم في
الأيام المقبلة. والجانب الرئيسي الآخر
لهذه الصفقة هو أنها تسمح بدخول
كميات كبيرة من
المساعدات الإنسانية والوقود والأدوية
والمياه والغذاء التي تشتد الحاجة إليها بدخول غزة  قال الرئيس بايدن أن
هناك آليات معمول بها
لضمان وصول تلك الإمدادات إلى المدنيين
وليس إلى حماس ما هي تلك الآليات
وهل لديك أي مؤشر على أنها
موجودة أم أن حماس فعلا
استفادت من هذا
التوقف
جيدا أولا آنا هناك
آلية التفتيش أه  الإسرائيليون في معبر
اسمه نيتسانا يقومون بفحص جميع الشاحنات
قبل دخولها عبر
معبر رفح إلى غزة أه ويقومون بالفحص
للتأكد من أنها في الواقع
إمدادات إنسانية وليست بضائع
يمكن أن تساعد حماس في حملتها العسكرية
ثانيا  تذهب الشاحنات إلى UN
Depot وإلى المنظمات الإنسانية الأخرى
التي تم فحصها
والشركاء الموثوق بهم وبمجرد أن تصبح
في أيدي الأمم المتحدة
والمنظمات الإنسانية يتم
توزيعها مباشرة على الناس وقد
شهدنا هذا العمل على مدار العام.  في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية مع تزايد
المساعدات الإنسانية، أه
رأيناها تنجح في
وصولها فعليًا إلى الناس وعدم
تحويلها إلى أيدي حماس
ولكن هذا شيء يتعين علينا مواصلة
التركيز عليه بشكل مستمر
الرئيس بايدن  يبقى على اتصال وثيق
مع القيادة الإسرائيلية بشأن هذا الأمر ومع
قيادة الأمم المتحدة ومع الآخرين
للتأكد من
وصول المساعدات إلى حيث تنتمي، وهو
الأشخاص الأبرياء الذين يعانون